la tête dans les étoiles tyloo nous
voyage dans le firmament
le graff est finie laïque du haut de sa
nacelle l'artiste à terminer l'oeuvre ce
soir en plein coeur des camélias les
habitantes du quartier jeunes et moins
jeunes apprécient le travail du graffeur
tout comme l'hommage rendu au chanteur à
la voix de velours en l'an 1000 heures
le photo des deux pylônes charente c'est
un grand copain est un copain d'enfance
depuis longtemps la grange devant moi un
honneur pour nous de maths est ce mieux
fait de façon que tous les genevois ali
étiez là toujours à travers cette belle
image en fait
la fresque a été réalisée dans le cadre
du festival réunion graffitis qui a eu à
coeur de s'implanter dans le quartier on
a commencé dans la dans le quartier de
château morange parce que c'est pour
nous c'était important
c'est un quartier on a commencé à
graffer ya très très longtemps donc on a
quatre fresques fait dans lé château
morange une aux camélias et l'autre sur
la médiathèque de saint denis et parmi
les fresques remarquable il y à celle de
deuil
une jeune graffeuse qui a apprécié les
changes avec les résidents sur sa
pratique artistique
il y avait beaucoup d'interactions les
gens étaient très réceptifs en fait bas
au travail qu'on était en train de faire
il y avait beaucoup d'interactions les
gens étaient très réceptifs en fait bas
au travail qu'on était en train de faire
de voir l'évolution au fil des jours au
début il comprenait pas trop il disait
banal à poux
repeint la façade les jeunes filles
surtout été très étonné de voir une
femme à monter sur une nacelle et graff
et à la bombe s'est pas uniquement
réservée à la gente masculine et quand
on a envie eh bien on peut on peut
s'imposer quoi le festival réunion
graffiti s'achève et ce soir c'est un
peu la fête au pied des immeubles par
ses fresques et cet hommage à tiloun
c'est tout le talent des habitants et la
convivialité du quartier qui est
célébrée